la vida cotidiana se detuvo en la
capital india nueva delhi este sábado el
país asiático ha notificado más de 230
mil infecciones por kobe 19 en las
últimas 24 horas lo que eleva el número
total de casos a casi 14.5 millones una
cifra que sólo es superada por la de
eeuu
ante este ascenso continuo de casos el
gobierno impuso un toque de queda
durante todo el fin de semana en nueva
delhi y medidas restrictivas en las
regiones más afectadas
el problema del cierre es que nosotros
los trabajadores jornaleros que ganamos
entre 1 y 4 dólares al día a dónde vamos
a ir cómo vamos a comer acaso va a venir
el gobierno a pagarnos este salario
diario más de 10 mil negocios de inia
han dejado de funcionar durante la
pandemia siendo las pequeñas y medianas
empresas las más perjudicadas en ese
contexto han aumentado las críticas
contra el gobierno por su gestión de la
crisis parte de la población cuestiona
la celebración de las fiestas religiosas
así como de los mítines políticos para
las elecciones locales por un lado se
disparan los casos de ccoo y 10
y por otro los líderes dan me tienes en
los que ni ellos ni sus partidarios
llevan máscaras esto es algo sobre lo
que hay que reflexionar cómo va a votar
la gente si no está viva para hacerlo
mientras tanto la organización mundial
de la salud declaró el viernes que la
variante del cobi 19 aparecida en india
podría ser más contagiosa
avn ciudad es misión social tenzing es
preocupante porque hay una similitud con
las mutaciones que confieren una mayor
transmisibilidad y algunas de estas
mutaciones también dan lugar a una
reducción de la neutralización lo que
puede tener un impacto en nuestras
contramedidas incluyendo las vacunas con
the vaccines las autoridades advierten
por otra parte que el principal
cementerio musulmán de la capital para
las víctimas del cuvi 19 se está
quedando sin espacio